tu
mais là
les vignes ont tous les domaines
es tu tombé là
cali
tout le monde est fait
ces gars là
espace il est
sinon
tarbes l'accord
espace parce que la grèce
nous
couffoulens au pied des corbières un
village de 320 habitants dont marty
chanteur occitan et l'instituteur est ce
que par hasard tu n'es pas un drôle
d'instituteur je préférais être
instituteur drôle la provision
d'instituteurs indépendamment d'un but
du fait que pour moi c'est quelque chose
que j'aime me faire c'est aussi une
espèce d'aspirateur à réel qui me permet
de les chanter et inversement
tout ce que j'accumule lorsque je chante
c'est à dire des paysages déjà dû
conscience des volontés de lutte et de
survivre tout ça je l'accumuler d'un
mois et ça repasse ensuite pour les
enfants dans la place ce qui fait que
finalement lorsqu'on me dit qu'est ce
que tu étais hostile au defender
je suis instituteur chan tabac
oui c'est vrai ça aussi c'était quoi
malo pas loupé les affame pour moi c'est
c'la jeu à linge général de la rue
messier sais pas si c'est un pari pour
demain quoi soucier finalement ainsi
tout ce à quoi on croit des mouches
ce qui le métro manoeuvre ceux qui le
vivent très mal
ce qui m'intéresse son petit le village
convoi isilon léger rhein sud ouest et
la plaine vers l'ouest par dessus du
moulin monia le château et puis ça voilà
l'art bleu c'est quoi respirer et et
amour des femmes ou durban voilà petit
blanc c'est qu'ils me montrent là les
éléments mais trois situe près sa
voisine
et bien comme il faut c'est plus que
craquer sg la largeur de tout homme qui
ont fait ça pris une belle rouste
attendus dès lors des vignes on y va
les toits et ce qu'ils payent aussi tu
vas y tomber y en a qui font pas appel à
villebois de cette année après être
arrivé à roanne brûlés
un peu plus et on m'a surpris
le midi et un pays de tradition c'est un
pays de faux club et la chanson un
certain moment a une résonance est un
aspect politique est la marque qui
apporte quelque chose
c'est cette une chaleur qu'il apporte
aux gens du midi et c'est un message
qu'il apporte aux gens hors du mythe
marty est certainement le point de
liaison dans quelque chose qui vit dans
une incompréhension très très grande
ne pas perdre
ces cadeaux ces maillots aux nouvelles
plateformes
les maillots
de nouvelles places
il repassera est sécable se décalera
gobelins
ce cas là
lévi noël yoga
lévi noël
haïti
respect
m
ces cas là
saleh
cette nouvelle salle des douits noël
soit l'heure
les blu ray dans l'air je me suis mis à
chanter comme ça par génération
spontanée je ne l'avais plus assez
lointain prochaine des pour moi pour les
amis et et puis alors il ya eu l'exemple
de la après ce cette malheureuse à mai
68 on a quand même beaucoup penser à ce
qui était possible à ce qui n'était pas
possible et à côté on avait l'exemple de
la trachée ce catalan avec ramon qui
avaient beaucoup remué la catalogne et
nous on s'est dit mais pourquoi pas ici
alors ici et moi j'ai essayé de chanter
comme un saint homme de dossiers des
choses que je voyais
émile vitesse mort dans les vignes il ya
tout juste un peu plus d'un an il y à
une violence dont on ne parle jamais et
il faudrait peut-être en parler c'est la
violence économique c'est la violence
que subit l'homme ou la femme qui doit
partir de son pays pour aller travailler
très très loin c'est la violence que
subit les parents qui voient partir leur
une femme c'est la violence de l'ouvrier
sous payés et donc finalement l'usiné
ferme c'est la violence des marins
pêcheurs se désiste en cela la
méditerranée qui ont eu des problèmes
avec les différents aménagements
touristiques du littoral avec la
pollution de la mer toutes ces violences
la même parle jamais en parle j'ai pu
utiliser société henri fabre qui
visaient l'homme d'un seul livre la
violence s'est pas c'est pas seulement
lorsqu'on fait un bouquin jeunes moins
jeunes larmes
la violence la vraie violence c'est
celle qui consiste bannière de chez eux
des dizaines et dizaines de milliers
d'hommes
remarquez la faute
quelle drôle c'est qu'apple rempli de
francs
l'espace on va prouver dans le pas la
même vision en tant que la rouille
fleurs
ce baladeur
ça marchait pas mozart
avis aux amateurs quant à l'histoire de
l'ontario venti façade libertà
ça va être super g ou de données
c'est nelson boula figure c'est que 17
saviez lassus c'est une star au kilo
basque jusqu'à ministres alliés bakayoko
la plume et les griffures signé la pole
à gran madrid fran vazquez del dominique
et le ska et amen amen savait que 17 kg
par le colonisateur
10h12
savez ce que c'est
ce que du sel salle et les u17 savez
vous ce que dit cet appel à ses services
extérieurs